I love seeing movies like this because I
get to review them chernobyl Diaries is
the newest creation from the guy who
brought us the Paranormal Activity
movies and if you saw those movies and
you know what to expect me going to this
one it's a very handheld very
documentary esque style thing with a lot
of scares and jump out things and noises
and loud booms and weird stuff that
seems like it could be scary but it's so
distorted and off camera and way way way
over there that it could be anything we
follow a group of young teenagers led by
Jesse McCartney
let me let that sink in moving on on
this very low-budget tour into the
disaster site of Chernobyl now the
radiation levels are extremely high
there and the tour guides like looking
for only here for like a day it's not
gonna affect you it's gonna be fine
yeah yeah let's do it's gonna be great
all right cool the first time I mention
the movie are pretty terrible it's just
basically they're just walking around
and they're talking and it's like the
worst dialogue ever and looking back on
the movie it's like it doesn't even seem
like that was part of the movie Jesse
McCartney wants to propose to his
girlfriend it's gonna be so beautiful
the other guy has the hots for the other
girl it's wonderful there's these two
random people who are like these outdoor
extraordinary extreme tourism people and
you got the tour guide this huge giant
guide he's the guy who's like local idea
that is where the the fish are larger
look there's a larger fish there look
it's a big fish you should touch it you
should touch it
oh they touched it and wiggled in
there's a big boom and we're all scared
now I really honestly love seeing movies
like this I do because there's something
so fun about reviewing them yes this is
a pretty bad movie but I will say though
that for about a half hour section of
this movie it wasn't terrible once the
the tour guide goes off and something
happens and then there's these dogs and
these strange mutant things are pounding
on the band everything there's like a
30-minute section there where I was
genuinely semi interested that's an
oxymoron I apologize the production
value is actually really good I really
bought the location I like the look of
the deserted area you know there was
like a ferris wheel there it was all
over
and everything and the walls were all
nasty and you know just that dilapidated
and everything it looked cool but
eventually it just devolves into the
same the same the same you know running
through the corridors things are
pounding on the walls the plastics gonna
go I don't know it's just a lot of the
same stuff over and over again after
movies like scream happen in movies like
cabin in the woods happen where they
continuously just show the tropes of the
horror genre where these characters just
make the dumbest decisions ever and
you're like dude you are stupid man
that's not the thing to do right now man
you're in Chernobyl but the thing is the
characters are obviously so dumb because
who would accept a tour into a disaster
site with his radiation everywhere where
they're just out to have some fun now I
will say the acting is serviceable right
it wasn't like jeez god you are terrible
like even Jesse McCartney was
serviceable there isn't like a
performance where you're just like oh
and without spoiling anything as the
film draws to a close and you learn more
about what these things are and
everything and you find out like what's
going on it's it's terrible it's it's
just it's really stupid there really is
no payoff to the movie when you go to
see these found footage films and they
all kind of just end the same way
they're just staring at the screen like
yeah well that's too bad that's okay I'm
gonna leave they end the same way
they are all the same I can't spoil it
for you but they're all the same Jesse
McCartney was in this movie I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm still laughing at that
there are some scares in the movie that
worked there are some times in the movie
where I felt tension but after a while
it gets to that point where all the
horror movie tropes come out all the
cliches from all the horror movies just
come out and since found footage films
are so common now there's like a whole
group of cliches for those type of
movies too and this movie has all of it
I would say if you were with a group of
friends and a party at your house or
you're having some kind of get-together
and this movie came on the sci-fi
channel at like 2:00 in the morning that
is like the one place where this movie
belongs to me so noble tyre is is dumb
it's dumb I'm gonna give it a d-plus
don't waste your money if we're gonna
see a movie I guess go see men in black
3 see if you like it check out the
Avengers again also if you didn't see my
lethal weapon review that I posted I
really would love if you guys check that
out
it has a short film at the end that I
did when I was a teenager it has my very
first fight scene ever I put a little
snippet of that in honor of the fight
scene Lethal Weapon let me know what you
guys think of that and as always guys if
you liked this review you can subscribe
to my channel and get stuck my dies
[Music]